most kids are coming home from their
second day of school with ccsd some
parents still trying to get their kids
registered for school that's right well
the district has made changes to the
shared housing process through which
proof of residence is verified jeremy j
ford reports
it's just frustrating is what i'm
hearing from parents after leaving the
education services building with
everything from waiting in long lines to
providing certified paperwork in order
to get their child into school it's
really stressful because she could have
been in school since yesterday monica
felix tells me she's been trying to get
her child in school for over a week but
due to the ccsd process she's had
problems they asked me for all these
things they asked me to email ccsd which
i did i never got a response and she's
not the only one frustrated brianna hall
is also having troubles getting her
child enrolled the frustrations are they
have us pre-register these students for
school
and then we still have to turn around
and go up to the school
students schedules are not ready then
they want us to bring in these forms yet
again superintendent dr jesus jarrah
says the district warned families
parents always wait to register or come
in and there's there was a change in
process we've centralized it but we've
been communicating dr jarrah says there
was change for verification purposes and
parents should be patient you know
there's going to be some
delays in bottleneck and but i we are
deploying staff there as well to make
sure that we expedite and get our kids
in front of our educators in the right
schools in their classroom some parents
claim the process was changed without
any notification and are upset their
child is missing school it's been two
days this day this is going to be day
three tomorrow because i'm still not
done with the process jeremy j ford live
local now
jeremy thank you for that well to ensure
that your child can attend school
through the shared housing program
parents must show notarized proof of
address the child's immunization records
a birth certificate and proof of
identification of course you can find
more information on 8newsnow.com